we now have as of this recording 71
percent of precincts reporting in Monday
night's Iowa caucus I will talk later
about how Iowa should not be the first
in the nation primary more on that later
or tomorrow the results didn't come in
to us on Monday night because of the
total crash of the technology used to
report results in Iowa and we had a very
embarrassing 24 hours for the Iowa
Democratic Party and for the Democratic
National Committee and 62% of results
were released yesterday Tuesday
afternoon as of this recording we've
gotten another nine percentage points of
the results 71 percent have been
released most analysts believe that Pete
Budaj who is now leading will be the
eventual winner of the Iowa caucus now
remember these are proportional delegate
allocations so it will be a
mathematically meaningless victory for
Budaj edge relative to Bernie Sanders in
the grand scheme of things but we'll
come back to that looking at the results
as of a few minutes ago Pete Budaj edged
with just under 27 percent of the
delegates Bernie Sanders with just over
25 percent of the delegates
despite as you might notice Bernie
having more votes in the popular vote as
of discounting you'll notice Elizabeth
Warren in third place with about 18% Joe
Biden in fourth place with 15% and Biden
followed very closely by senator Amy
Klobuchar with about 12 and a half
percent of the vote the only other
people getting any delegates are Andrew
yang with one percent and Tom Styer with
0.3 percent everybody else including
Michael Bloomberg and Tulsi Gabbard with
literal goose eggs just zeros now
without going into the detail the reason
that Pete can have more delegates while
Bernie has more raw votes it's similar
to how you can win the electoral college
but lose the popular vote the way Donald
Trump did in 2016 the delegates are
apportioned at a local level and you can
win some precincts with a big popular
vote margin but then lose a lot of
little priests are a lot of lose a lot
of other precincts by small margins and
end up with a popular vote win
without the most elegance we don't yet
have the final numbers in the end more
than likely this will mean 10 pledged
delegates for Pete and 10 pledged
delegates for Bernie they might end up
differing by one or two that's as of
right now we are still waiting on that
last 29% of the vote this does not put
anybody in any kind of a decisive
position we will very quickly get
another democratic debate this Friday we
will then go right to the New Hampshire
primary on Tuesday which will be 24 more
delegates in total Bernie right now
very much in the lead in New Hampshire
so remember this is one of four
primaries before March 3rd Super Tuesday
the delegates are apportioned
proportionately and the DNC is
increasingly panicking about Joe Biden's
poor performance and Bernie's good
performance we'll talk a little bit
later about the idea that's being
floated about giving super-delegates the
power they had in 2016 which had been
taken away from them in New Hampshire
Bernie Sanders remember Bernie won
handily in the 2016 New Hampshire
primary he had about 60% of the vote to
Hillary Clinton's 38% massive victory in
New Hampshire in 2016 but again it's 24
delegates Iowa was 41 New Hampshire is
only 24 the big repercussion here is not
for Budaj edge or for Bernie the big
repercussions here are for Joe Biden Joe
Biden's terrible performance has shaken
the establishment to its core and later
in the show we're going to dig into that
in more detail Elizabeth Warren's poor
performance also leading to some deep
thinking about her future she got just
four pledged delegates and is currently
polling in fourth place in New Hampshire
very unlikely New Hampshire will give
Warren any momentum there was a report
yesterday I don't know if it's been
confirmed that she has been canceling
and rescheduling a lot of planned travel
to both Nevada and South Carolina the
third and fourth primary states it does
not seem like things are going well for
Warren and really they haven't been for
about I think about six or seven weeks
at the
point that we've been covering so those
are the numbers as of right now in the
Iowa caucus results by the time you
watch this clip by the time we published
today's show we may have 100% of the
results or closer to it but generally
speaking these are the results a over
performance by Pete Budaj
significant under performance by Joe
Biden and Bernie Sanders roughly
percentage-wise with the level of
support that the polls indicated going
in make sure you're following the David
Pakman show on Instagram for more on
this and other stories at David Pakman
show